So, let me show you how that goes wrong. When we define my_append, we create
this new list. The default parameter gets initialized to this new list object
which is currently empty. Then, we make our first call to my_append. There's no
default parameters so within the body the value of lst is this object, we append
to it. So now, after the first call, the value of lst is a list containing one
element, apple. We can see that p has the value that we expected. Now, if we
call my_append, again passing in just a single element, well, instead of the
value of list having an empty list, it's going to have the value apple. So, what
we will get back for q is the result of appending orange to apple, which is the
list apple, orange. The moral is that we should avoid default parameter values
that are mutable objects. This can lead to really hard to find bugs that can
take many hours to figure out if you're not careful. There is a correct way to
do this, which is to assign the default perimeter to an immutable value. Here,
we'll use the value, None, and then every time it's called, we're checking if it
has the default value, None. If it does, we initialize list to a new empty list.
Note that this happens every time my_append is called so every time we'll get a
new empty list object, instead of modifying the same one, which is what we're
doing before. This example is taken from David Goodger's excellent document,
Code Like a Pythonista: Idiomatic Python, and there's a link to that below.